good morning everybody here are a few
stories we think you'll be talking about
today the amber Geiger murder trial may
be over but the investigations continued
during the trial the Dallas Police
Department was accused of misconduct
during the both of chante murder
investigation this surveillance video
was entered into evidence in it you can
see sergeant Mike Mata leaned into the
patrol car that Geiger was sitting in
and tell another officer to turn off the
dashcam prosecutors allege he was trying
to protect Geiger and hide evidence our
Omar Villafranca asked him about that
accusation during the trial hürmüz said
that when you were talking to Amber
Geiger and you asked for the camera to
be shut off that you should not have had
to shut off because the only person who
has the power is the lead investigator
and the attorney correct you say that's
false
the only reason that camera I asked for
that camera to be off is because the
attorney was calling the officer and
that is attorney-client privilege and
that's a right every citizen has
regardless if you're a police officer
not- says he actually welcomes the
internal police investigation because he
did nothing wrong
helps me understand why there's protests
outside but you hear from the the both
of Jon's families there they're somewhat
pleased with the outcome getting the
conviction you still have this anger in
the community I think this helps explain
it the investigation is ongoing yeah